hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Lauren
gah so today we're gonna sweat our asses
off because it is really hot haha Lauren
no air conditioner sorry man dude is he
covered in sweat today yeah we're gonna
watch the international trailer for Dumb
and Dumber to Oh have you seen the
trailer no I'm not seeing you did you
see the first one yeah but that came out
like 20 years ago so did you do you
remember laughing at it I do I do
remember laughing at it okay it's one of
my favorite comedies I never thinking it
was really funny in that they were
really dumb I think that's the point
with this with this trailer I saw for
this one I was actually pretty letdown
because I was like they look like
they're playing caricatures oh oh it was
pretty actually upsetting yeah I don't
know maybe the International trailers
different there's a lot of people who
think it still looks really funny so
what's your Lorna say yeah let's see
what lauren has to say
favorite candies
mean what
I thought it was better the trailer than
the other what this one gave me a little
bit of I mean I get that kind of humor
that they're trying to go for I love Jim
Carrey and I expect a lot from him and
you're right this is kind of
disappointing it's it's a little bit
caricature yeah and that's my problem
it seems forced like let's try to be as
wacky as possible it doesn't seem how
fun tickets at all yeah and it's like I
mean I haven't seen the movie in a very
very long time so I don't remember
exactly what they were like in it I
agree it does it's very I mean it looks
dumb like that's just what it's not city
boy yeah I know that Ryan makes fun of
me all the time that I never laugh
whenever I'm watching these videos like
it's Jim Carrey we should be laughing
and like I think there was like a
chuckle yeah and I had a good chuckle at
one point but I expected to be in
stitches no she's not in sting she is
not in stitches we do not have to call a
paramedic see I laughed more just now
that I feel like I laughed at the day I
think that it was just a really long
time and they were bored and they're
like well let's with all the roommates
what happened trying to seek will come
back yeah cuz Jim Carrey hasn't had a
good run in a while yeah his last movie
he's been in I think it was yes ma'am no
it was a movie about to where he's gay
and he's a con artist I know I love you
Philip Morris that was a cool movie oh
that was a good movie I do love how Jim
Carrey
to come out with really serious roles
yes he has a lot of great versatility no
I totally agree
Jim Carrey's is like I really appreciate
like his humor but [ __ ] that realtor was
like dude I kind of liked what he was
doing do yousee yes man
weird huh did you see yes man and then
you said no that's not that's funny to
me I know anyway if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe here oh here
yeah yeah okay yeah there's a lot of let
you get away with these days yeah if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe and Lauren from what my
personal understanding you have recently
started to actually do something with
your YouTube channel sort oh I guess so
I have a YouTube channel because you
just like have one when you start
watching videos and it's connected to my
Google account or whatever yes so I have
a YouTube channel and then since I've
been doing videos with Ryan people have
started subscribing to my channel which
is weird because I didn't have any
videos now we're gonna do a shout-out
you were a cheerleader right yeah yeah
you come across like a true leader okay
good once it's cheerleader always a
cheerleader someone like that I suppose
no good arguments we gave this guy shout
out what happened was Marie and I give
this guy a shot okay and we sometimes
like to tease a little bit me yeah and
we got a little carried away and
actually a fan I think I don't know if
he's like playing around like you know
there's a line is open there's too many
comments now oh dang he keeps going like
he starts there but then it goes up oh
wow no good arguments chill the [ __ ] out
no it's a [ __ ] YouTube channel no we
know he was a little in
and people think I'm a real [ __ ] stop
I'm a nice guy in real life I'm okay I'm
okay
I know I wasn't there so hate him but
love me how's that sound
yeah I'm but I'm wanting to make a
public apology okay thanks thanks I'm
you're a very supportive right person
and bring on the chance right this
moment
dad don't Margie no you man wanted a
shout-out so I brought along an asian
girl who's gonna shout out to you go
shout out that's right buddy guys you
got a really cute girl to say your name
that's an accomplished outed it yeah
shout it out it is shouted it where
people can hear it and where she
probably blew up the mic a little bit
hey but that's okay
if you're wearing headphones I'm sorry
don't wear headphones guys no not cool
anymore man no be blast nation in your
car do a mr. Ely's shuffle shuffle give
me a shout-out business tribe sense of
policing review mr. lacell
because the shuffle is all in capital
letters o applies and it would be one
word year instead of like L a capital S
shuffle yeah now you make sense your
ability on vocabulary you know it is
very seductive your knowledge of words
that's a weird thing to be attracted to
but it's just how I honestly feel and
see if it wasn't for mr. love shuffle
yeah I wouldn't have realized how much I
feel this way about you at this very
moment all right